my book maximalist America in the world
from Truman to Obama is the story of
American foreign policy since World War
two and it looks at the two modes of our
policy the ways in which we've
interacted in the world
I call these maximalism an all-out
approach to problem solving military
political economic and retrenchment
pulling back after a period of over
extension particularly after military
defeat you write a book like this and
you have to wrestle with the question of
how important individual personalities
are because you've got a lot of
distinctive personalities who occupy the
presidency and you have distinctive
advisers among them maximalists andrey
trenchers have a kind of cyclical
relationship to each other the
maximalists produced a big response they
overreach they make a mess the retrench
errs come in with downsized policies to
clean up the mess they then tend to
under do where their predecessors have
overdone their policies don't seem to
work American power seems to be ebbing
and a new consensus forms that you've
got to have a more activist policy and
to re-enter the maximalist with new
ideas for how to regenerate American
power that cycle has been repeated three
four times since the end of World War
two I think to look at the history of
American foreign policies to be very
impressed by how determined presidents
are to follow the course that they want
the picture that we have of presidents
who were just swayed this way and that
by public opinion I think is actually
not quite right these are rather willful
committed people who think they know in
where the country ought to go I was
surprised to discover how long Lyndon
Johnson for example really resisted
getting into the war in Vietnam he was
the last person in his whole government
who was willing Dan ravine in in Vietnam
he resisted a rather strong a set of
pressures from the media from his
advisors from political rivals to get in
in the end he succumbed and when he
succumbed he then became a pretty strong
maximalist in pursuing the the war in
Vietnam one of the presidential stories
that surprised me particularly was a
president that I worked for and as a I
was a junior staffer in the National
Security Council under President Reagan
and the historiography that has
dominated in our study of President
Reagan of late has been one in which
he's described as a immensely flexible
empathetic conciliatory person who
manages to reach out to Mikhail
Gorbachev and to reach an agreement
about how the Cold War should be ended
what struck me in looking at President
Reagan was how rigid he was while being
genial and affable and empathetic this
is a person who drew as much on his
acting talents as on his labor union
negotiators past I can't think of an
example of rigidity in negotiation that
quite rivals President Reagan's approach
to arms control negotiations with the
Soviets and I think it had a rather
significant effect
he was a real maximalist in our in the
story that I've tried to tell
proponent of all-out effort but he stuck
with it in it at a time when a lawful
lot of people in his own administration
we're telling him look we can go for a
deetle here we can go for compromises in
general presidents are not pushed this
way in that by public opinion and
congressional opinion they tend to
expect actually that their foreign
policy is going to be unpopular and
that's one of the reasons that they have
to do things quickly and and on a
maximalist basis they need to get it
over with
because they don't expect to be able to
have the support of the American people
for unusual measures for very long
president's call in time of crisis for
their advisors to give them every
measure that they can think of that is
an appropriate response they rule that
some of the crazy ones but they tend to
give a sympathetic hearing to almost any
plausible scheme that's in in maximalist
mode retrenchment turns out to be a
rather similar you get very different
presidents Eisenhower Nixon Obama maybe
George HW Bush are our retrenchment
presidents these are very different
people and yet they call on their
advisers for the same kind of advice how
can we scale down how do we deal with a
crisis situation where we'll overcommit
it we're spending too much we're losing
too many lives were losing American
prestige and power and their responses
tend to be rather similar to and even
though the individual presidents are
quite different